what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
video titled
why i hate men and it's by a
girl um just so you guys
know i used to be not like super crazy i
hate men
but i definitely understand like like
i've been there
and i had a realization where i realized
it was the men that i was choosing to
date
and i really had to do some like inner
work and reflection as to why i kept
picking guys you know like that um but a
lot of girls haven't had this
realization
and have it i don't want to say like
realize that they're the problem
nobody's forcing you to date those guys
but i just i just gotta say it
ah they're gonna come for me i know
before i start
hit that subscribe button please like
hit it click subscribe follow the
channel you guys get it you already know
the deal
so i hate men
so just just before i start
this is gonna sound bad this girl
is like some like i'd say she's like
pretty right
not super like out of this world
phenomenal hot
but like cute right like she could
definitely get male attention
and what i found is girls that are like
slightly like average to above average
or like the angriest because they can't
get the they like pick guys that treat
them like an option
because they kind of are
like you know when i've been there like
i'm not gonna pretend like i've never
been in that situation but
you can either
like find guys that value you or
continue to make the same mistake over
and over i don't i don't know if that's
what she did
but i'm about to find out hi everybody
it's janae
and i am here with a video talking about
how much i hate men and why i hate men i
have a couple
little stories to tell you about some of
the [ __ ] that's happened to me
like with disgusting men and hopefully
once you guys like listen to these
stories i was telling somebody
funny like something that happened me
and like what men like say to me and
stuff
like this guy and he was like what the
heck that's so weird i'm like
listen men need to talk to each other
about what is appropriate and what is
not appropriate
to do and say to women
i'm gonna just be real for two seconds
there is no universal standard of what
is appropriate and what is
not appropriate i'll give you an example
i've seen
a million tick tocks saying do not
approach women in the gym they're there
to work out
when i i'm not single now in a happy
relationship my boyfriend's great
when i was i would not have minded i
actually would have been pretty excited
but there's no standard like guys can't
read your mind
you know it's like some of you are fine
most of you
are like literally [ __ ] clueless and
stupid
and very very scary we're gonna start
with because they can't they can't read
your mind sis
and that's okay like they can't read
your mind
worries about like times when i've been
out and about
and also yes i'm literally like wheezing
right now like i can't breathe because i
gained like
20 pounds guys not 20. i think like like
15 pounds
i've gotten so big i don't know how
but it's okay i just wanted to know guys
that's why i'm breathing so hard because
i'm a fat [ __ ] so one of the things i
really [ __ ] hate that men do
is talk to me in public i'm really
really sorry but
stop like that's one thing to come up to
me
at like a bar or that like or a club or
something
but when i'm just out trying to do my
goddamn grocery shopping i really don't
want to talk to anybody let alone men
i was out grocery shopping and i walked
to the store because i don't have a car
so
i walked my happy fat ass to the store
and like one of the first things that
happens to me
is this guy like comments on my height
he's like oh you're so
tall if you're getting taller you're
going to touch the ceiling and this is
me
that's my literal face because i
literally i don't know what to say like
don't talk like stop talking another
okay that wasn't
i i wouldn't really care if someone said
that to me but i'm pretty laid back
i wouldn't tell a guy i mean i'm not
gonna act like i know
all about picking up women i don't but
like i probably i probably wouldn't
recommend
that line but like if if a guy came up
to her and said hey you look beautiful
can i get your number
or something like that you're gonna be
mad
why because you're at the grocery store
you can look good at the grocery store
time i was harassed by a man in public
this always happens like when i'm
walking because i don't have a car
and so when i'm [ __ ] walking places
there's always gotta be
somebody to harass me always
i was walking back from my friend's
house it was [ __ ] scalding hot i was
drunk
i was full and uh there was a concert
going on i told you guys i live like
right next to
this is i also noticed that women that
hate men
tend to go to places where not
quality men are like party all the time
and
they like clubs whatever and then they
hate men but it's also like
based on where you're choosing to meet
guys concert like stage
and i was walking home and uh this guy
like comes up to me like
runs across the street to talk to me and
he's like
oh do you need some tickets for the show
i'm like no thanks he's like oh what
kind of music do you like blah blah blah
and he like keeps like trying to talk to
me i know he's like trying to do
business or something but it's still
like
creepy and so finally i'm like i stop
walking and i turn around and i'm like
can you please leave me alone
and he's like wow that's funny
what is so funny about a girl not
wanting to be harassed walking to her
home
like i'm obviously not headed to a
concert the concert was for like some
sort of honky tonk [ __ ]
confederate flag ass heaven i don't know
who it was like rascal flats or
something i don't know
rascal flats that's like half pop
obviously i'm not going to that [ __ ]
like it made me really mad
and it made me mad that he like reacted
that way to me saying leave me alone
that's why
but why are you allowing yourself to get
like being mad is a choice
and you're still hovering over and
replaying the situation in your head
it doesn't have to be that big of a deal
when i went to india
i went to india a couple years ago
people literally follow you around
and like beg you to buy things
practically
i didn't care just don't buy [ __ ] keep
moving you're good girl
and like that's why i think sometimes
girls don't know how to like set the
boundary and say
hey like
i appreciate the you know tickets
whatever but i'm not interested have a
good night like
that probably would have ended the
conversation don't like tell me
no and tell men to stop talking to us
and stuff like that
because you guys are going to react in a
way
that is kind of off-putting
guys do do this sometimes like there's
been times where i've rejected a guy
and they get so mad like but not not
like
to the point i think i'm gonna be
attacked or anything it's just like oh
you're ugly anyway
like that definitely happens but i think
i'm just too laid back
who cares keep walking keep moving
another time when i was [ __ ] walking
home
it was literally like 90 degrees out i
had a bunch of [ __ ] groceries
it was so hot i was like halfway home
and this [ __ ] guy like drives past me
and i'm like okay
and then he ends up doing a u-turn in
the street and comes up to me like
we don't have sidewalks because
charlotte north carolina is not a place
to like live if you don't have a car
like
walking places in north carolina is not
easy okay
so i'm walking on the grass and he like
turns over into the grass like literally
this close to me
and so i continue walking trying to keep
my cool
and i look at him he's got the window
now and i'm like are you
okay like and he's like i'm okay i was
just about to ask
you the same thing bae i was like leave
me alone
please don't come up to women who are
all by themselves
walking to their home and harass them
and try and make them like get into your
car like
okay the car thing that's weird i'm
gonna give her that one that's weird i
i can't kind of i've watched too many
like true crime stuff and like human
trafficking stuff that if a car
comes by me and like slows down when i'm
alone it actually really freaks me out
um there's a solution to that though if
i really wanted one
and i've really felt that strongly about
it you you can buy a gun especially
where would you say south carolina
you can buy a gun honestly there you go
solution
that's just how i am solution minded i
he could have been nicely trying to ask
me for a ride but then he calls me bae
and that's like horrible like don't call
me bae i'm not your bae i will never be
your bae
i'm a random girl i'm trying to just get
home
like i'm telling you guys it was 90
degrees out this
mile from my house but i would literally
walk a mile in 90 degree heat
and get in a car with a strange [ __ ]
man who's gonna drop me off at the place
where i live so he knows
where my house is like well yeah i don't
that's fine just
but just say no keep walking doesn't
have to be a life altering
experience that's a little bit scary i
don't live in a house i live an
apartment
another thing that happened to me one
time i've been trying to [ __ ] tell
the story for so long
but i never know exactly how to tell it
to make it more entertaining so i
thought i would include it here
i was in high school and i lived in a
house where the neighborhood had like a
creek
uh it's a creek or lake or pond i think
it was greek
so me and my stepsister we're both 16
and we go down to the creek blah blah
it's all fine
suddenly i see a snake and that is like
a bat omen
i look up from the snake and there is a
old strange
there's a strange old man like just
appears out of nowhere
my stepsister is terrified so i have to
be the one to like
somehow get us out of this situation and
make everything calm so that neither of
us get abducted or raped you know like
please stop going up to women when
they're all by themselves
like there was nobody at this creek so
like there was no witnesses or anything
like
that's so scary guys this guy's like
why probably like 50 60 years old coming
up to these two
girls who are all by themselves he's
talking to us about his job he's talking
to us about how he was in like the cia
or something
um but okay so this is a different
issue um i mean obviously they're young
i actually agree with her in this last
one that's definitely creepy
if like an old man's trying to talk to
like a 16 year old girl
but the issue like there's always gonna
be creepy men no matter what like that's
gonna be an issue
and there's no man that is creepy that
you could say oh just don't be creepy
too
and he's going to say oh
well yeah let me just not be creepy
anymore and you know
oh i forgot whoops my bad no they're
always going to be creepy men so
i do think it's important for women to
learn to be more assertive
and it's something a skill that i
actually would like to learn and get
better at
because i think women are just naturally
more agreeable and like
you know upbeat happy nice
and a lot of times when guys like do
creepy things they don't know how to
like
be firm and stay in a firm tone tell
them to like back off whatever
um but i think that was more the issue
there she was young
but it should be a conversation that her
dad had with her
my dad didn't have that conversation
either i wish he did and
he like looks at my my stepsister
and he's like she's so scared of me
isn't she and i'm just like trying to
laugh it off trying
i'm trying to keep him like somewhat
entertained enough to not
kill us finally i get like my phone out
of my purse this is back when we had
keyboards on our phones remember that
guys
and i like go behind my back and text my
stepmom my step-sister's mom
and like try and call her and text her
so she knows that we are in a bad
situation and that we need to be picked
up from
this place because this literally like
probably went on for about 10 minutes
he finally like just walked away but my
dad like
found out from my stepmom and he was so
limited like he was screeching through
the neighborhood like came to pick us up
in his truck like
we tried to look we tried to like drive
around and look around for him but he
was nowhere to be found but like
that [ __ ] is so [ __ ] scary like so
scary
yeah no that is i could tell you guys
everybody who's watching
i don't care if you're a girl tell your
boyfriend tell your brother tell your
dad tell your grandpa tell everybody you
[ __ ] know if you're a boy tell your
boyfriends
do not go up to women who are all alone
okay
that was my video that's all i really
have to say
i think men are disgusting i'm taking a
break from them for the rest of the year
because i'm sick see this this
a bad attitude i
look at i think men are disgusting this
is the problem girls like this
when men hear that they believe you so
when you say i want to take a break from
men
guys will say okay and you end up by
yourself
and like everything you do in life is a
risk so you open your heart up to
someone
it's a risk and you might get burned
like that might happen
but like the solution isn't
i hate men just like the solution for
men isn't like all women are gold
diggers
uh they only care about my money
like girls say the same thing guys only
care about looks
they just want sex dude
when that's not you know that's not true
about everyone and if that's if that's
the way you think
i think that you have to look inside and
and say
like why am i picking these people
because if all of your relationships end
the same way the common denominator is
you
anyways let me know in the comments um
did i get anything right did i get
anything wrong
you guys know i'm pretty open-minded so
yeah just let me know in the comments
don't forget to subscribe
bye guys